We’re all familiar with viral diseases,
especially over the past two years.
The deadliness and severity of a virus cannot
be understated, whether it’s COVID-19, influenza,
or any other of the countless infectious diseases
that plague humanity.
We’re all familiar with the bubonic plague,
the black death which wiped out an estimated
25 million people in the middle ages, a third
of Europe’s population at the time.
But that was during an era in which medical
advances were limited to the sickening practice
of bloodletting, which drained a patient of
their blood until all bacteria left their
system, or washing the body with vinegar.
Of course, none of these methods had any effect
in staving off the Black Death, and the epidemic
went down in history as one of the darkest
periods of civilization.
But for all our technological and medical
advances in the field of health and medicine,
infectious diseases are still as much of a
threat now as they were back then, if not
a greater one.
Think about it, in today’s world, everything
is heavily connected.
Globalization means that we travel more, import
more products than ever before, and with such
a high population density, it’s difficult
to keep anything under control due to the
sheer amount of people there are in the world.
Complete eradication of a viral disease has
proven extremely difficult in even the strictest,
most regimented campaigns to do so.
Vaccines, while effective, still require time
to develop, roll out, and treat.
Take for example the Smallpox virus.
For centuries, this deadly disease slayed
entire populations, killing millions with
a mortality rate of 40%.
In the 20th century, the world’s governments
and medical organizations worked tirelessly
to come up with a vaccinated cure for the
disease, and their efforts eventually paid
off.
A successful vaccine was developed, and only
the trinkling of cases of smallpox were documented
in Somalia in the 1970s.
Today, all that remains of the disease are
contained samples held in high-security laboratories
across the world, explicitly used for research
purposes.
But Smallpox’s story is not the norm.
Other diseases you may not realize are still
lurking in the shadows are polio and malaria.
Polio being a disease affecting the central
nervous system, with weakened muscle function
as a result, and Malaria being a mosquito-transmitted
sickness that results in severe fevers and
vomiting.
The common perception is that these illnesses
aren’t actually a threat anymore, and are
nothing more than a relic of the past, but
that isn’t quite true.
While they’ve been eliminated from some
parts of the world, in Polio’s case, most
first world countries such as the United States
and Europe, still have some documented cases
that crop up from time to time.
But the future is hopeful, with only under
50 cases of polio documented worldwide in
the year 2018, and Malaria’s worldwide eradication
programs seeing success year by year, maybe
the world will one day be fully wiped of these
terrible illnesses.
But why are we telling you this during a video
about the SCP Foundation?
Because the subject of today’s video is
also a deadly virus, but unlike the more ordinary
variations we just discussed, this one is
going to be a lot more difficult to eradicate
fully.
And by difficult, we mean next to impossible.
As to be expected with an organization like
the SCP Foundation, the threats they deal
with are both similar to the ones the rest
of the world’s governments and large organizations
do, and entirely, completely different.
If you’re a seasoned viewer of SCP Explained,
chances are you’re already familiar with
more than a few anomalous viruses.
They’re unspeakably deadly, incredibly strange,
and can put an infected victim through more
pain and suffering than anything else in the
world.
It’s a testament to the Foundation’s thoroughness
and capabilities that some of these diseases
are even able to be concentrated in a manageable
dose and contained inside a chamber at a secure
facility.
But for others, they’re still out there,
ready to strike at a moment’s notice, and
there’s absolutely nothing the Foundation
can do about it except be as swift as possible
in their retaliation.
And there’s no doubt that they’re prepared.
With the deadliness of an anomalous virus,
which can spread at a more infectious rate
and potentially alert the rest of the world
to the supernatural happenings of the SCP
Foundation and the objects they contain, an
anomalous pandemic is one of the Foundation’s
greatest fears.
Some anomalous diseases, as we mentioned before,
are under the control of the Foundation.
Take SCP-008, nicknamed the Zombie Plague,
for example.
SCP-008 is a deadly virus that, you guessed
it, can essentially turn a patient into a
zombie, reanimating their corpse after the
sickness kills them.
What makes SCP-008 unique is that it’s entirely
absent from the natural world, save for the
places the Foundation has labeled “G2 Sites”.
These G2 Sites are small pockets across the
world in which the Foundation discovered SCP-008,
which further research of such have determined
that the disease may not have originated on
earth in the first place.
Subjects infected by SCP-008 display symptoms
within three hours of infection, which include
flu-like symptoms preceded by a coma, which
is followed by death.
But after death, the victim’s body will
continue to display lifeless signs of mortality,
including a high durability to damage and
a desire to ingest living humans on physical
contact.
Just like a zombie.
Research into SCP-008 is highly classified
and left out from the original document, because
the Foundation has the right to fear that
SCP-008 may be replicated in an unsuspecting
laboratory one day.
As such, containment efforts to prevent such
research from bearing fruit are in place,
backed by the Foundation’s stranglehold
over the ordinary scientific world.
Thankfully, SCP-008 has mostly been destroyed,
with samples contained solely at the G2 sites,
which are now protected Foundation facilities,
located across the world.
But the Foundation was lucky that SCP-008
was so easily contained.
If the disease spread in larger numbers, or
originated from a natural source on earth,
we might be living in a world more like a
zombie apocalypse movie than the one we know
today.
On the other side of the spectrum, you have
SCP-3519, the “Quiet Days” virus.
In one reality, SCP-3519 managed to kill off
the entire world, due to its severity and
ease of infection.
Unlike most anomalous diseases, SCP-3519 was
a memetic virus, meaning that its transmission
wasn’t just limited to the traditional means
of physical contact, but the very idea of
it permeating your mind would allow it to
take root inside your body.
SCP-3519 permeated the idea that the world
would end on March 5th, 2019, and that self-termination
was a preferable option than living through
the apocalypse and the terrible aftermath
that would follow.
SCP-3519 took society by storm, and the idea
was transmitted through television broadcasts
and news stories encouraging people to free
themselves from the world, and even Foundation
sites themselves.
The Foundation was powerless, and the rapid
rate of transmission proved too difficult
for the organization to keep fully under control.
The project to create a cure was greenlit,
but one by one, as Foundation sites across
the globe suffered massive die-offs and a
loss of personnel, the research team dwindled
down until there was only one person left,
a junior researcher by the name of Rory Jones,
who assumed the position of O5-6 in an emergency
succession protocol that would promote the
next highest member of the Foundation to the
position in the event of an Overseer dying.
Jones was the only member of the Foundation
left, and as far as he knew, camped up in
a cabin in the woods with nothing but a few
research materials and a computer terminal,
the only man alive.
The SCP-3519 timeline’s story proves just
how quickly a deadly anomalous virus can get
out of control.
How it can make an organization as all-powerful
and ever-prepared as the SCP Foundation just
another statistic in a record of infected
populations.
But you don’t need to tell the Foundation
that, they’re already well aware, and they’ve
had decades to prepare, study, and analyze
the effect an anomalous virus can have on
the world.
And that brings us to the mysterious case
of the main anomaly we’ll be looking at
today:
SCP-217 - The Clockwork Virus.
Dr. Charles Gears, a researcher of note that
you may have heard of before, was one of the
Foundation’s best and brightest.
His cold, distant demeanor and propensity
for researching the anomalous commonly associated
with the divergent religion, the Church of
the Broken God, a group of zealots focused
on reassembling the broken, metal pieces of
their mechanical, technological god, made
onlookers associate the Gears name with sleek,
careless alloys, and methodical, cold clockwork.
When the Foundation began observing symptoms
of what would later be labeled SCP-217 in
a major population center whose name would
be scrubbed from all official documents, they
knew Dr. Gears was the right man to head the
research efforts.
For years, the Foundation had observed strange
medical records and reports from the city.
Reports of dementia in subjects younger than
the common age brackets and at an uncommonly
high rate.
High reports of lethargy, depression, emotional
dulling, and a feeling of something moving
underneath the skin, or a ticking noise in
the ear, were all signs that the Foundation
was dealing with SCP-217.
Dr. Gears was already familiar with the disease,
having worked alongside efforts to study it
in the past.
This was not the first major population area
affected by SCP-217, and there surely were
more areas up next.
Upon arriving and reading the initial reports,
Dr. Gears requested to view a subject that
the Foundation believed was suffering from
SCP-217.
When the young woman entered, Gears immediately
recognized the signs.
The stiff movements, the robotic, monotone
voice, and the way that nothing he seemed
to say phased her.
They were all clear cut signs of SCP-217’s
infection.
The girl was barely high school age, but she
looked like she had all of her youth and life
sapped from her completely.
It was a horrible sight to see.
An X-Ray was performed, and Gears saw for
himself a definitive sign that SCP-217 had
taken over her body.
The X-Ray imagery showed the inside of the
girl’s body, which had been converted from
an ordinary mass of organs and tissues into
a clockwork machine, composed of cogs, gears,
screws, and wires.
And as Gears knew, this would only get worse
as time went on, with signs of her infection
appearing outside the body as well as inside.
Right now, there wasn’t a shred of human
tissue left inside her, and there was nothing
the doctor could do about it.
Gears thought about the girl’s family, who
had been amnesticized prior to the Foundation
seizing their daughter for research purposes,
and though the emotionless man would never
let his facade down, on the inside his heart
ached for her.
But it wasn’t only her, it was dozens of
people inside the city the Foundation had
documented as displaying symptoms of SCP-217.
On a scale this high, there was little the
Foundation could do except sit back, watch,
and only act when the symptoms became too
visible to hide.
That was the tragedy of SCP-217, the clockwork
virus.
It wasn’t deadly, but it was a slow, more
metaphorical death, from a person made of
flesh and blood, to a clockwork automaton
that felt more like a shell than a living
thing.
The Foundation was more than familiar with
SCP-217 though, and multiple samples are held
inside a reverse-pressure airlocked containment
chamber at a high security site for research
purposes, in hopes that one day a cure could
be developed.
Personnel wanting to access SCP-217 samples
have to don fully insulated hazmat suits,
with chemical sterilization and endure a
post-interaction quarantine period, with physical
testing.
All this being mandatory after they have finished
their experiments with the virus.
The severity of an SCP-217 infection can not
be understated, and any items touched by infected
personnel have to undergo a strict sterilization
process.
The Foundation is perfectly justified in this
overly cautious behavior too, because SCP-217
has an infection rate of 100%, meaning that
it will transmit through physical contact
all of the time, without failure.
But it doesn’t just infect humans, the clockwork
virus has been observed to infect all multicellular
organisms.
From the smallest insect to an elephant, SCP-217
consumes and hollows out all it can.
Clockwork beings wrought from a clockwork
virus, marching to the ticking of their innards
in a hollow, empty world.
If that sounds terrifying and like a nightmare,
then congratulations, chances are you’re
unaffected by SCP-217.
If it sounds appealing, well, you might just
be a Mekhanite ready to serve the Church of
the Broken God.
But we’ll get to that connection later.
SCP-217 is especially difficult to deal with
due to its hardiness.
It can survive for years outside a host body,
and when it does find a suitable host, and
trust us, there’s no shortage in supply
of them in the world, it can sometimes take
years for symptoms of SCP-217 to manifest.
It’s a slow virus, and that’s exactly
what makes it so dangerous.
The Foundation might not realize a large population
area has been infected before its too late,
and that’s exactly what happened before,
with entire towns being infected by SCP-217.
But what are those symptomes?
Well, you might have been able to guess so
far that SCP-217 has to do with turning someone
into a mechanical monstrosity, but there’s
a bit more to it than that.
SCP-217 alters bio-chemistry in such a way
that causes organic matter to re-arrange itself
into an organic metal.
Chemical scans of this metal reveal that there’s
still living, cellular tissue and DNA present
inside it, but it takes the appearance and
feels indistinguishable from actual materials.
This process occurs slowly over time, and
advanced stages have shown that a subject’s
interior will resemble a machine, with a complicated
mixture of gears and clockwork.
This is subtle, barely noticed by the patient
at first, with only vague feelings of confusion,
insomnia, and joint stiffness, but as larger
and larger parts of the body are converted,
the subject experiences extreme pain.
As Dr. Gears wrote in his research notes on
SCP-217: “Hearts are replaced by gears and
small tubes, joints by gear networks, eyes
by structures not unlike primitive “hand-crank”
film cameras, etc.”
SCP-217, in non-mammals, shows first on the
outside of the body.
In mammals, such as humans, SCP-217 converts
the internals before being visible on the
outside of the body.
The reason for this is unknown, but it might
have something to do with that Broken God
connection we mentioned earlier.
One of the Church’s core beliefs focus on
‘ascending’ humanity to reflect Mekhane,
the Broken God.
While the origins of SCP-217 are unknown,
if the virus is related to the Mekhanites,
this subtle, slow infection may be a part
of their grand design, a plan to covertly
infiltrate society and convert the masses
into effigies of their god.
But of course, this is all speculation.
As we mentioned, those infected by SCP-217
can be entirely unaware of their conversion
until it’s too late.
But aside from physicality, the mental state
is also affected.
From the middle to advanced stages of SCP-217
infection, victims' behaviors reflect their
cold, mechanical insides.
They respond in a repetitive, disassociated
fashion.
Their actions are dull, mechanical, and telegraphed.
They’re easily distracted and confused,
and appear irritable when faced with new problems.
In the early stages, SCP-217 manifests as
increased lethargy, a lack of emotional response,
and a feeling of “fluttering” or “moving”
underneath the skin.
Always present are ticking noises, like those
of a clock, that mainly manifest when SCP-217
infects the shoulders, neck, and head.
But attempts to hear this noise using recording
equipment have invariably failed, as the device
will not pick up any sound if pressed against
an affected area.
As SCP-217’s infection advances, the subject
will experience excruciating pain.
Sharp, tearing sensations in the areas that
are being converted into organic metal, comparable
in feeling to a knife wound or a deep muscle
tear.
This feeling can persist for hours or days,
depending on which area of the body is being
affected and the subject themselves.
After tearing the existing organs, the new
parts will integrate into the tissue and settle
into the body, producing pain.
An analysis of this newly formed organic metal
appear to be alloys of the brass, steel, and
iron varieties, but substances such as leather,
rubber, glass, and wood have been observed.
And observed is the key word, because as soon
as these materials are examined deeper, it’s
revealed that they’re still organic in composition,
and even carry the subject’s DNA.
Organs and tissues affected will, however,
become stronger.
Instead of being squishy meat-bags filled
with tissue, blood, and other parts, they
take on the physical properties, namely durability,
of the material they resemble.
If one of these areas are damaged, they’ll
repair over time, just like regular organs,
but at a much slower rate.
But one interesting note is that a damaged
piece of organic metal can be repaired, so
to speak, by replacing damaged areas with
new parts of the same type.
This has had no consequences, and the body
will continue to act as normal.
That’s one benefit of being infected by
SCP-217, you can essentially repair yourself
with whatever you have access to.
But the conversion of a victim doesn’t stop,
it continues to occur until their entire body
is organic metal, inside and out.
Dr. Gears’ research on a fully converted
brain was apparently so ground-breaking that
it had to be erased from the standard security
class documentation.
We can only speculate on what it contained.
Possibly that connection to the Broken God
that we’re so desperate to make?
We don’t know, but whatever it was, it hinted
at something far larger than what a cursory
look at SCP-217 seems to suggest.
SCP-217 is truly one of the most dangerous
anomalous viruses the Foundation has to deal
with, having already infected hundreds of
people in various population centers around
the world before containment methods can be
properly established.
So if you happen to start hearing the sounds
of a tick here and a tock there, accompanied
by a strange fluttering feeling under your
skin, we’re sorry to say, there’s not
much we can do for you now.
Actually nothing.
There’s nothing we can do.
Now go check out “SCP-914 - The Clockworks”
and “SCP-001 - The Broken God - Ouroboros
Cycle” for more Mekhanite related videos
from SCP Explained!